The control channel is the one frequency
on a trunked system that never carries a
voice — and it is the only one worth
decoding first.
Tune across a trunked site and you will
find it immediately: a strong, continuous
data carrier that never stops and never
speaks.
That is the control channel — the system's
coordinator.
It carries a nonstop stream of short
signalling messages: registrations, call
requests, and above all, channel grants.
Every message answers a question some
radio just asked.
A radio powers on: the control channel
registers it.
A user keys up: the control channel grants
the call and names the channel it will
happen on.
Because it announces where every call
goes, locking onto this one frequency
makes the entire system's activity
visible.
Its counterpart is the voice channel — or
traffic channel.
Control carries data and coordinates; a
voice channel carries an actual
conversation, and only for the brief life
of a single call.
A grant points a talkgroup at a voice
channel, the audio flows, a short hang
time keeps replies on the same channel,
and then the frequency goes idle and
rejoins the pool.
The messages themselves are compact,
fixed-format bursts, packed back to back
on a fixed-rate downlink: TSBKs on P25,
CSBKs on DMR, and their equivalents
elsewhere.
Between grants, the stream also broadcasts
the system's identity, a list of neighbor
sites so radios know where to roam, and
periodic status that keeps idle radios
locked.
And the announcements repeat.
A radio that arrives mid-call — it was out
of range, or just powered on — hears an
update for the call in progress and joins
late.
That trick, late entry, only works because
the control channel keeps narrating the
system's state over and over.
Most systems dedicate one frequency to the
job permanently — P25, DMR Tier 3, TETRA —
which is the easy case to find and
monitor.
Lighter DMR modes rotate the control
function around the pool on a rest
channel, and some systems interleave
control signalling with voice on the same
carrier.
For GopherTrunk, the control channel is
the map.
Decode it, and every call on the system
announces itself before it starts.
GopherTrunk parses the grant, affiliation,
and system messages in real time, tasks a
receiver at each granted voice channel,
and follows many conversations from one
wideband capture.
Finding an unknown system works the same
way: hunt for the carrier that is always
on and never talks.
So: the control channel is the data-only
coordinator of a trunked system.
It announces every grant, registration,
and system parameter.
Decode it first — it is the map to
everything else.
Full write-up linked below.